a rough week for the banking industry
the collapse of Silicon Valley Bank is
causing shock waves across the entire
business world
a big Bank just died we've all heard
about it everyone's talking about it and
we gotta talk about it because something
big is going on here as of this morning
Silicon Valley Bank or svb has gone
under completely the second biggest bank
collapse in U.S history the bank is
called the Silicon Valley Bank or if
we're going to call it svb in this video
it is the epicenter of tech startups
venture capital and it is now
effectively dead the government is
scrambling to keep us all calm while
this Bank fails your deposits will be
there when you need them the American
banking system is really safe and well
capitalized that's because we live in a
system that doesn't work if everyone
freaks out at the same time
the system relies on all of us keeping a
feeling of safety if that doesn't happen
the system falls apart and that's what
I'm going to explain today so let me
show you how this happened